VKORC1 is really important in the pharmacodynamic processes
of Warfarin. So let's learn a bit more
about how we go from gene to protein.
VKORC1 can be found on chromosome 16 of the
human genome. Chromosome 16 is about 90 million
base pairs long. And the VKORC1 gene can be
found about 1 3rd of the way down
the chromosome. The gene itself contains three exons spanning
more that 4,000 base pairs of DNA.
After transcription and splicing, the resulting mRNA has
492 nucleotides of coding region between the
start and stop codons. And after translation, you
end with the protein with 163 amino acids. Now there is one allele of the
VKRC1 gene that's associated with enhanced warfarin efficacy
but the mutation isn't in the coding region
of VKRC1. It's in the non-coding region. About 1600 base pairs in front of
the start of transcription. So based on
what you know about saturation, if the mutant
allele increases warfarin efficacy What do you
think the net effect of that mutant allele
is on VKRC1 transcription? Do you think
it increased the transcription or decreased the transcription?
Remember that Warfarin binds and inhibits
VKORC1 which normally promotes blood clotting.